what about aids and stuff
[Laughter]
well i trust aids
[Laughter]
i trust aids do you a's is doing a great
job at what it does i'm not saying you
should be doing it right i'm saying it's
it's it's it's a fantastic yes it's
sufficient you know yeah yeah like 9 11
you had to end the sorrow
and the anger and the and the rage and
the sadness you had to go dude [ __ ]
bull's-eye
i'm glad you said it because i can't you
know what i mean something
lord have mercy they were masterpiece
would you say yeah yeah
yeah somewhere
for sure i wish they hadn't
sure but
because of all the people that died well
they really nailed it they [ __ ]
nailed it dude yeah
and i think they see it that way they
can appreciate one of my favorite
stories about it was uh there was a
documentary about it on pbs after and
they talked you know they tried once
before with the with the truck bomb
one notorious b.i.g sang about i think
it was 19 like 95 or 96 yeah i remember
i was living here
and uh 93. so they got the one of the
guys they that did it they took them
they were taking them they talked to a
cop this is a great interview
he just had a [ __ ] rain man moment
right there
i think it was 93. it was nice 5 or 96 i
think it was what was 93 wasn't that
what was that the somalia
the black hug it was
was the bombing
let's go list let's [ __ ] go okay
the [ __ ] oh
i know my bumming and then 2004 was 911.
the guy the guy that gets the 93 bombing
but
okay that's a great galifianakis joke
when he says uh someone said what where
were you on 9 11. and he says what year
[Laughter]
funny guy oh man very good sorry bbs pbs
pbs did a documentary so they uh
interviewed a
marshall a federal marshal who escorted
one of the perpetrators of that first
bombing to his trial
in manhattan and they had him in a
helicopter and they're flying to the
courthouse so he's next to the prisoner
and they're flying right next to the
world trade my god this guy and the
federal guy the fed marshall is just a
cop
he says i pointed at the buildings and i
said you didn't get him did you and the
guy just called he said we'll get him
wow
whoa what language and they did those
buildings are no longer there
yes
they're no longer there they are no
longer there that might have been where
you got the idea flying up there he's
like oh this is the way
yeah that federal marshal probably was
the inspiration for it he was the music
you know that might be true he was the
muse for the night of life yeah he saw
from the air [ __ ] from the thank you
buddy from the air and he's probably
asking like how do you fly that thing
he's probably asking little questions
right there it's his phone i don't know
if he was thinking of using that
helicopter it could have been i think it
was more of a those crashes from the air
yeah you were you started out really
smart you got stupid at the end oh now
they're stupid what yeah see that's what
i'm saying you people go in and ask you
to let people know when they're being
dumb or stupid what they're saying is
stupid yeah it's a good word it's a good
evaluative word
are you projecting something maybe
do you feel stupid yeah a lot of times
yeah yeah tell us about that i feel
stupid all the time
every day
really when did you feel stupid today
you big dummy
i'll tell you last time i felt stupid
i was in a swimming pool on a paddle
board teaching myself the paddle board
in a swimming pool okay
and
i was starting to really nail it
and somebody was watching me and i was
showing off and then i wanted to jump
off of it like you know i wanted to
dismount and splash but i had gone into
the very shallow part of the pool so i
cracked my [ __ ] knee
on the bottom of the pool and then i
couldn't do anything for the rest of the
day
that was stupid yeah that was dumb that
made me feel stupid that's why i call
him stupid too
to get it off and get it off of me on to
him you got to cleanse the palate i'm
comfortable why not i don't know i had a
scared moment on a stand-up paddleboard
in aruba it was like really when you do
the stand-up panel where if it's really
windy you become like a sale yes it's
bad if it's coming at you it becomes
really work and i couldn't [ __ ] move
and i was really struggling
and a guy that was swimming went hey
just step off of it
i was in like three feet of water
so i just got off and like walked back
with the paddleboard but i was like
doing [ __ ] this and i couldn't get
anywhere and he's like yeah you just get
down
now joe can i ask you the last time i
was stupid that was it 2005. and then
you that was the year after 9 11.
nailing it
nailing it ever since
are you uh a great actor joe
are you kidding no give me give me an
emotion what do you want me to do
asian veterans jesus asian asian people
oh i fought hard
in the wall it's an asian veteran that's
beautiful yeah
let's survive asian asian veterinarian
can you do that um asian vegetarian hey
but give it a shot wait that wait
i [ __ ] up that was italian oh
whoa your dog is sick
but i made a choice you see good actors
make choices yes
he's a great actor when it comes to
making choices that's the thing 100
percent yeah joey's a really great actor
he's a great natural actor and
as evidence was the first choice the
movie that we made